james says talk about an overview on why
society has given up freedom for the
illusion of safety because people want
free
[ __ ]
you can't have free [ __ ] without giving
up freedom
just the way that it works
so what does the state do what does the
government do it says here you can have
this for free you can have this for free
but
you have to take our jab when we tell
you to but we're gonna give you money
and it has to be spent on whatever right
um
you're gonna see central bank digital
currencies being programmable money by
the government telling you if you're
asking for free [ __ ]
how and what you can spend it on and
possibly when you need to spend it you
might only have access to that money for
15 days for it to get pumped into the
economy i was talking about this with
george gammon the other day on my plane
and win podcast you should go check it
out it was an awesome talk
i'm going to have them on again in the
future but
that's what people vote for and you know
when in doubt you know when we talk
about women too it's like you know don't
listen to what they say oh i just want a
nice guy i can cry on his shoulder and
he's got to be sturdy and reliable and
you know she'll go off and bang chad
thundercock because he's the exciting
guy so you watch what they do you don't
listen to what anybody says the same
thing you know with people's voting
patterns watch what people vote for the
government that you get is a government
that you deserve if the vast majority of
the population wants free [ __ ] and they
vote for a big ass incompetent
government that you know hands out free
[ __ ] at the expense of your freedom
then just take a look around at your
neighbors and your peers right
uh okay let's keep going down a few more
of these
how your family influences the way and
how you deal i don't know what that
question means
try to be clear when you ask these
questions on the community tab guys
oh here's a good one talking about
education
uh university self-development etc so i
did a video the other day i think it was
the last one that i released in fact
where
it's for 20 year old guys that are going
to university
college any kind of post-secondary
where they might be studying for
something um in a co-ed environment
let's say where there's you know men and
women in the environment
the importance of education isn't as
significant as it used to be
even even when i was a kid like if i'm
being honest
even when i was a kid the importance uh
placed on getting a college degree or a
university degree was insignificant
today even more so if i'm being honest
uh you should never let school get in
the way of your education
i want you to listen me say it again
never let school get in the way of your
education and i'll tell you what i did
the
the last
i think i had six months left of college
and my dad was starting up this business
and he had the sales
road trip that he needed to do
i was i was a young man at that point
right
so he said look you know i'm gonna do
this trip i think you're gonna learn
something from it but you're gonna have
to take time out of school
college you know the time to get through
it and i'll tell you what in the four
days i was on the road doing sales calls
to different customers that he was
setting up doing some business with
and the social aspects of in the travel
aspects of it and the meeting and the
boardroom and all that stuff and i'm a
young man wearing a suit that doesn't
really fit me properly
watching what's going on you know with
these people i learned more in that four
days than i did in two years sitting in
a classroom
and that's even worse today because not
only do you generally not need to go to
post-secondary for anything unless
you're going to be a doctor lawyer
accountant
surgeon like anything that requires a
professional designation piece of paper
fancy foil on it with little letters
after your name framed a mahogany it
goes on the wall and tells people that
you're important
if you don't need one of those
i wouldn't recommend going to any kind
of post-secondary because not only do
you know sort of waste the time and
money and not only the debt part of it
because you're probably not going to
have the money from your family or a
grant
but also the element of
the toxic environment that it actually
is today right because it's it's been
overrun by
toxic feminists you know for being
honest uh if you go back and watch that
video that i did the other day for a
friend
these kids are dealing with things that
i never had to deal with when i was in
in school
our our biggest problem then was like
well does she like me because i just
want to get the girls up and today it's
like well that is a problem for them and
then it's like if they make contact and
something happens or there's intimacy or
there's interest
these girls can file me too's like
like
it's it's just believe all women there's
there's no evidence that's required at
first you're guilty until proven
innocent and
i've seen lots of kids thrown out of
school unable to complete their degree
had had their degree stripped of them
unable to
um you know completing the mandatory
testing that's required required to
complete all because of a point and
sputter
from
even a girl that uh
had uh had been ghosted by a guy you
know for example he just didn't like her
and didn't want to see her again saw
what she was made of and she made up a
me too allegations sort of thing so i've
seen these things happen
and i don't think that the importance of
education
exists today anymore i've i've been
saying this for years actually i've made
several videos talking about this
whether it was a podcast form or i was
being interviewed by somebody i've
talked about this many times
uh
look i gotta show you this one oh i can
put these up on the screen while i'm
while i'm at it here so
check out check out this guy's handle
um
this one over here says it's got a
picture of fat derrick and it says less
dates more on my plates
anyway that's a that's a channel that
i've watched i didn't realize there was
parody accounts out there commenting on
my [ __ ] um your take on the dating wheel
world in its present state versus the
past as well as how it is in different
countries where do i move if i don't
want to settle for having a family with
a 304
i think the where do i move part is a is
a moot question
right like go to where you're treated
best and
as i stated earlier be maneuverable you
know if if where you're at doesn't work
out for you anymore can you pick up and
move and go somewhere else
i don't think that people are
setting up lives and worlds today
like my great parents great grandparents
did where they would just buy a plot of
land farm it get you know some small
livestock or a little bit of livestock
um and then you know live in the village
on a few acres of land
married to your uh you know the first
girl that ever touched your pee
until kingdom come because that's just
the way that things have pretty much
always worked back then
uh the present state today is very much
different so
the where do i move part
i don't
i don't do the where do i move i don't
prescribe locations you know you guys
are grown ass adults you can figure it
out for yourself
but um
maneuverability and um picking a place
that you treated best but more
importantly are you well sorted
because
i'll tell you something i've talked to a
lot of guys privately that do the where
do i move sort of thing
and they think they're sigma males or
some [ __ ] like that like some like
outlier that's like a a special kind of
alpha but they're really just beta males
um
and moving somewhere if your belief
system is already broken means that all
you're doing is you're moving from an
environment that's potentially more
hostile still being a plugged in beta to
an environment that's potentially less
hostile towards men and fathers
but
you get my point right it's it's the
whole unplugging thing hey guys i really
hope that you enjoyed that short clip if
you did consider supporting the creation
of content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you